hey guys
Greg footpeg here it's my new name
anyway I just got back from doing a
sleep study and I started catching up on
Game of Thrones and I got a notification
that the teaser for the trailer of
spider-man homecoming just released now
if you know me I'm usually pretty anti
like teaser for teaser trailers
especially like the 5 to 6 second ones
before an actual trailer because think
they're like really nothing you can
really go off of too much and it's
easier for wait spider-man all right
we're gonna do it no more exes you the
movie you know oh I'm so sophisticated I
don't like teaser for teaser trailer
stuff because I'm pretty [ __ ] Z this
like so a 17-second but I gotta watch it
where's the case okay you see the case
yes where's the case okay thank you see
the case
that's cool it's cool man he's got this
alright I mean that's a nice touch
bringing the spider wings there actually
didn't fully catch it until the second
time I was just so enthralled and I was
like spider-man again that's a great way
if you're like good or reboot spider-man
is like do something different with the
costume and they're bringing the edition
of like I think they're called spider
wings or the with the webs underneath
his arms that's really awesome man
that's like so [ __ ] old school I love
it that automatically makes this
spider-man even easier even another
reason to add to why he's much more
distinct already the tone and style of
just that 17 seconds like that that POV
shot I think he he'd might have like a
GoPro on in that moment possibly that
moment right there I'm just like that
whole vibe it was like so different than
the other spider-man movies we've gotten
already what this minor teaser gets me
excited for is like the different kind
of tone this movie's gonna have because
this feels like this will be distinct in
its own way you know it's definitely not
gonna feel like the amazing spider-man
how that was just a you know reboot of
like the first spider-man movie came out
this seems like this is gonna be
something entirely different
my understanding the webs underneath his
arms I don't know I think they were just
done for like cool-looking effect
I don't believe they actually serve much
of a purpose in his actual suit I'm
wondering since Tony Stark and I mean I
was a great addition of like because we
know Tony starts gonna be in this at
times that's a great addition of him
like building him a new suit and I
wonder if the webs underneath his arms
will actually have a bigger purpose this
time around like I'm not the biggest
spider-man reader so I don't know you
know if there are comics where it does
serve a purpose I just remember that it
kind of really did it then again though
the note does say a minor upgrade so
might just be I don't know I'm excited
for this look at way for the actual
trailer honestly just to tell you guys I
don't know if I'll have a trailer
reaction up because I am going to like
the first screenings that there that are
playing in LA
wrote one and it's supposed to play
before that movie but if it happens to
drop before I leave for the theater then
sure I'll definitely film one alright
guys thanks for tuning in subscribe to
the real rejects follow me on Instagram
and Twitter constantly posting nude pics
of myself that's what you got to do what
Instagram to make it big you got a post
bikini photos girls if you're watching
if you haven't no way of getting famous
just post half-naked photos of you on
Instagram fat skinny doesn't matter you
might be someone's fetish